un spectacle féerique c'est ce que
propose le zoo de thoiry
avec son parcours d'un kilomètre 5 de
lanternes on découvre des animaux des
animaux fantastiques des animaux
domestiques des animaux du zoo la mise
en scène la lumière n'est pas comme en
lumière les bruitages les sons c'est
l'enfant quand on se balade on est dans
un pays de rêve en pro d2 la tapa on
s'est levé à 17h45 à lundi branche
produits allient fille puisque
normalement le parcours thouaré lumière
sauvage se déroule le soir alors
couvre-feu oblige le zoo ouvre de 7h30 à
9h30 le matin on inverse la journée
c'est à dire que 7h30 9h30 on voit le
lever du soleil cette fois est pas le
coucher du soleil avec toute l'affairé
la magie qu'on peut trouver le matin
avec de la bombe et ses magnifiques
également une autre expérience et la
brume ce matin là était bien au rendez
vous et ce ne sont pas les horaires
matinaux qui ont arrêté les visiteurs
ont su lever à 5h30 mais bon ça me gêne
pas pour faire des bonnes choses comme
ça ça vaut la peine
ça fait quand même presque un nom qu'on
fait plus rien du tout et le fait qu'ils
aient
quand même réussi à ouvrir et à garder
au moins ça une petite respiration un
petit peu dans tout ce dans toute cette
vie un petit peu morose l'éveil de
thoiry devrait se poursuivre ces
prochains week-ends en attendant le
lancement d hébergement de thoiry au
printemps une expérience nocturne au
sein de la réserve des ours